bonjour à toutes et à tous ceux c'est
paléo news l'émission qui fait des news
avec du vieux alors j'interromps la
diffusion de un jour un fossile pour
vous parler de cette image cette image
c'est la reconstitution d'un singe du
miocène d'un singe vieux de 12 millions
d'années et pas n'importe quel type de
sage puisque vous voyez à l'absence de
que qu'il s'agit d'un grand singe donc
c'est l'un de nos plus proches parents
et il s'agit de danube husky a été
découvert en bavière qui datent du
miocène et comme vous pouvez le voir ce
grand singe est reconstituée bipèdes
donc ça y est on aurait enfin retrouvé
le plus ancien grand singe bipèdes et on
aurait enfin démontrer que ce que ces
grands singes était bipède bien avant la
bien avant la l'origine de l'homme donc
ça c'est la grande annonce que vous
pouvez voir passer en ce moment sur les
réseaux sociaux dans les médias
l'annoncé de cette découverte annonce de
la découverte de dan vieux ça a été fait
il y a seulement hier le 6 novembre je
poste cette vidéo le 7 novembre donc
donc ça risque encore de il ya encore
des des médias qui risque d'en parler
après que je poste cette vidéo est la
raison pour laquelle je fais cette vidéo
et bien c'est parce qu'il ya des
commentaires à faire là-dessus parce que
mine de rien si l'homme si l'être humain
était bipède enfin si les grands singes
était bipède avant le même l'origine de
l'homme bat ça change pas mal de choses
ça confirme ce qu'on appelle la théorie
de la bipédie initial donc la théorie de
la bipédie initial là je vais vous
parler de la vraie théorie de la bipédie
initial pas de l'espèce de fantaisie où
les grands singes étaient d'été semi
aquatique et il flottait grâce à leurs
gros cerveau pas cette théorie de la
bipédie nessia là dans la vraie théorie
de la bipédie initiale celle qui a été
développée enfin celle qui a été
développé des tonnes et des tonnes de
foie mais disons que là où elle a connu
un grand un grand bond en avant c'est
avec la découverte d'ardipithecus donc
c'est la théorie qui dit qu'en gros
l'ancêtre de l'être humain des
chimpanzés voire même peut-être des
gorilles étaient déjà bipèdes
voilà donc
et ça c'est une théorie qui manquait de
preuves main qui pour ainsi dire qu'ils
avaient même aucune preuve
très peu de preuves donc donc si on
démontre que la théorie de la bipédie
initial est vrai bave
ça veut dire que la bipédie n'est plus
un caractère humain et donc ça ça mérite
quand même qu'on s'y attarde de secondes
quoi voilà ça veut dire aussi que les
gens qui disent que ça elle entre aux
puces donc toumaï n'est pas un humain
ont peut-être raison
bah oui parce que si ça elle entre aux
puces si on enlève la bipédie assaël
entre opus il lui reste plus grand chose
comme caractère humain ont ils eu assez
petit cagnina usure apicale mais c'est
pas un caractère qu'on retrouve que chez
l'humain ça on le retrouve par exemple
chez les gigues anthony tech donc donc
donc voilà dire que danubius était
bipède et se lie à 12 millions d'années
c'est pas c'est pas rien c'est pas rien
parce que ça va s'il est si les grands
singes était bipède bien avant l'origine
de l'homme ça veut peut-être dire que ça
elle entre aux puces du coup n'est pas
un être humain ça ça veut peut-être dire
beaucoup de choses quoi donc il ya des
grosses implication derrière cette
découverte et je voulais vous en parler
de façon un petit peu critique
aujourd'hui parce que je viens de lire
l'article donc je suis en train de
réagir à chaud un de toute façon ça peut
être que à chaud parce que regarder ça
c'est l'article l'article il a été
publié le 6 novembre donc comme j'ai dit
on et le 7 novembre à aujourd'hui
donc voilà alors que j'enregistre cette
vidéo on né le 7 novembre donc là je
suis chaud là je suis à chaud je suis
bouillant donc voila et après avoir lu
cet article et bien déjà il faut dire il
faut bien dire que j'ai des petites
choses à en redire alors déjà on va on
va faire à propos les choses que je dont
je n'ai rien à redire
premièrement la liste d'auteurs la liste
d'auteurs je n'ai rien à en redire parce
que je ne connais pas la plupart de ces
gens c'est une équipe fortement
international avec des gens qui viennent
d'australie
des gens qui viennent d'allemagne à des
gens qui viennent de bulgarie il ya des
gens qui viennent d' indiana police aux
états unis
la seule personne que je connaisse et
david bergen enfin que je connais dont
j'ai déjà lu plusieurs articles on va
dire c'est david b gagnent donc qui
vient de l'ontario qui vient de toronto
au canada et donc david degen c'est un
grand spécialiste des dessins des grands
singes du miocène hors de or danubius
est un grand sage il nous vient du
miocène de 10 livres environ 12 millions
d'années donc jusque là j'ai aucun
problème avec ça donc la liste d'auteurs
j'ai rien à en redire
j'ai rien à redire quant à la
j'ai rien à redire quant à la au fait
qu'il reconstitue danubius comme biped
sache l'article m'a assez convaincu mais
je suis pas du tout du tout spécialiste
de ce point de vue là donc bon voilà je
suis convaincue mais je suis convaincu
de façon très très souple puisque comme
j'ai dit je suis pas du tout spécialiste
de la question de la bipédie fade
je suis pas du tout familier avec les
caractères post crânien qu'ils décrivent
dans cette dans cette étude
mais bon bah voilà faut bien dire que
quand on met quand on me montre ce fémur
là et qu'on me dit que c'est un fémur de
d'animal bipèdes j'ai bien envie de le
croire la tête de fémur et bien ronde
elle n'est pas ovale comme chez le
chimpanzé ou chez le jeu pas moins chez
le ch et un 2 chez un sarko pitt est
comme un babouin par exemple je veux
dire c'est une tête de fémur qui est
bien ronde elle est bien séparée du
reste de la du corps du fémur il n'y a
pas la grosse bosse là elle n'est pas
développé ce qui fait qu'elle bute pas
dans le bassin quand en posture bipèdes
vous voyez que la têtes de fémur est
orienté bien vers le haut quand même et
pas vers le côté donc on voit une
articulation du bassin qui vient de par
la coi qui vient du dessus sur cette
photo donc à priori j'ai envie de dire
alors la tête de fémur et séparés mais
les robustes 1oc allait les séparer mais
elle est relativement courte c'est
surtout ça l'important au niveau de la
du de la tête de fémur elle est bien
séparée du corps du fémur mais elle est
relativement mais cette secousse est
cette construction est relativement
courte et robuste donc ça c'est pareil
c'est un bon c'est normalement un bon
indicateur de bipédie donc je remets pas
en question vraiment le fait que danube
youth était bipède
voilà je remets pas en question
l'autorité des gens qui ont
qui ont publié cette étude donc voilà ça
c'est pour les choses que je ne
questionne pas par contre par contre par
contre il ya quand même des plusieurs
choses qui m'ont choqué à la première
lecture de ceux de cet article est alors
le premier
le premier c'est ça c'est vous avez
certainement vu passer ça tout à l'heure
quand j'ai quand j'ai scrollé vers le
bas le matos il est pas fifou enfin ils
disent qu'ils ont quatre quatre
individus dont un squelette quasiment
complet en partant du principe qu'ils
ont
sur cette figure ils ont mis le meilleur
matos qu'ils avaient enfin vous voyez
c'est quand même c'est quand même pas
fichu fif ou quoi
il ya quand même il ya quand même du jeu
passée s'est passé quand même vachement
craquelé c'est vachement déformés il ya
alors normalement sa cellule n'a si je
ne me trompe pas on va aller voir parce
que j'ai pas envie de vous dire de
bêtises c'est quoi c'est quoi voilà
cellule n'a voilà donc ça c'est annuler
na et alors vous voyez que sur lui il
n'a il ya même une grosse pathologie la
voilà donc ils disent dans l'arctique
qui a une grosse pathologie et donc sa
cellule n'a et voilà il ya une énorme
pathologie donc ça c'est pas en plus
c'est pas que de la déformation en plus
il ya aussi des caractère pathologique
sur leur squelette
donc ouais le matos et pas fifou donc
ils ont enfin voila il publie sa dans
knight joueurs en disant à squelette
complet machin tout ça aurait ce
squelette complet
faux ouais bon après je vais montrer ça
à une à une dame qui étudie les grands
singes fossiles et apparemment ça n'a
pas eu l'air de la choqué qu'on appelle
ça du beau matériel bon mois par article
moi personnellement j'ai vu des choses
mieux préservé qui datait du permien
donc qui était dix fois plus vieille que
ça vingt fois plus vieille que ça donc
donc mois déjà la qualité du matos elle
m'a pas impressionné donc à partir de là
faire des études morpho métriques donc
les des mesures et des machins sur les
sur la morphologie 3d de ces trucs là
voilà donc typiquement ce qui produit ce
genre de résultat et puis tous les
tableaux que vous pouvez voir dans l'est
dans les suppléments tahri data donc
dans les données supplémentaires là
toutes ces mesures tout c'est toutes ces
mesures tous ces tableaux là du coup
arriver à tirer un bon signal d'un
bateau ce qui est tout écraser tout
péter tout déformé
je trouve ça un peu je trouve ça un
petit peu douteux voyez tous ces boks
pelote là c'est ouais bon déjà ça ça m'a
juste visuellement déjà à se voyait
juste visuellement
j'ai commencé à me méfier et alors ce
qui m'a choqué ce qui m'a vraiment
choquée c'est ça c'est leur hypothèse
d'avoir découvert ils ont ils disent
qu'ils ont découvert un nouveau type de
posture
chez les grands singes dont qu'ils
appellent ça le extender l'ipcc le ring
et je crois que pareil si vous avez vu
passer ça sur internet il ya vous avez
certainement vu passer un titre du genre
une nouvelle un nouveau type de posture
découverte pour les grands sages
fossiles et donc le extender l'ipcc le
ring ce sera un nouveau type de posture
alors je sais même pas comment traduire
ça le club le ring ça veut dire grimper
ou suspendre donc le la grimpette la
grimpette à membres et tendu je sais pas
à membres tendu je ne sais pas ce qu'ils
ont voulu dire mais en gros c'est comme
c'est un peu comme les d'après ce que je
lis dans l'article
en gros c'est un peu comme les orangs
outans c'est à dire que c'est du ces de
la bipédie suspendu c'est ce que font
les orangs outans ils font de la bipédie
suspendu avec les bras sauf que là c'est
une bipédie suspendus ou les jambes sont
très fortes sont très puissantes
alors que chez les orangs outans la leur
bipédie suspendu les jambes sont très
faibles c'est surtout les bras qui
tiennent donc donc bah c'est ce qui est
représenté sur cette image je vous la
remet voilà vous voyez donc c'est comme
une bipédie suspendu d'orangs outans
avec les bras vers le haut comme ça mais
vous voyez qu'ils ont représenté la
puissance des jambes parce que les
jambes sont bien tendue et qu'il
soutient qu'avec un seul bras dans
l'arbre voilà ce danubius donc ce serait
ça là une bipédie suspendu avec les
membres postérieurs beaucoup plus
robuste beaucoup plus costaud et donc
bien bipèdes et ça moi ça m'embête ça
moi ça m'embête parce que si vous y
réfléchissez bien donc il crée à nouveau
type de posture pour cette espèce
fossile
alors moi j'ai rien contre j'ai rien
contre mais comment tu testes ton
hypothèse comment tu testes que cette
hypothèse est vrai comment tu testes
que ces caractères que tu vois sur le
squelette parce qu'il voit toute une
variété de caractère qui indique que les
membres postérieurs était puissant que
les membres antérieurs étaient braquées
ateurs comment tu testes que cette
posture existe vraiment s'il n'y a
aucune espèce moderne qui la pratiquent
parce que c'est ça le truc c'est qu'il
crée ça pour une espèce fossile ça veut
dire par définition qui a aucune espèce
moderne qui la pratiquent
alors il apporte des détails comme quoi
bein oui les membres postérieurs son
bipèdes et les membres antérieurs sont
son bras créateurs dont qui montrent
notamment si on peut voir les phalanges
les phalanges sont très courbé ça c'est
très typique c'est très très typique des
braqueurs
donc oui je peux être convaincu mais
c'est quand même un gros problème de
d'inventer un nouveau type de posture
pour un pour une espèce est apte pour la
simple et bonne manière qu'en gros tu es
en train de créer une hypothèse non est
stable puisque comme il n'existe aucune
espèce qui a c'est qui qui qui possèdent
ce type de posture qui possèdent ce type
de locomotion eh ben on saura jamais ce
que ça donne sur le squelette
on saura jamais ce que ce type de
locomotion fait au squelette donc dire
qu'un squelette à ce type de locomotion
sans avoir un équivalent moderne pour
tester cette hypothèse basse à rentrer
en hypothèses de locomotion montée
stable et ça c'est chiant et ça c'est
très chiant donc donc on a une hypothèse
note est stable et est là où j'ai
vraiment eu un mouvement de recul mais
de fou c'est ici donc le elle s'est donc
leur leur nouvelle leur nouvelle
locomotion est un nouveau modèle de mode
de positionnement ancestrale à tous a
enfin qui est un modèle de
positionnement ancestrale commun à
l'ancêtre commun de des grands singes et
des humains et au cas où c'est pas assez
clair leur nouvelle posture donc la
bipédie bipédie arboricole bipédie
arboricole membres postérieurs renforcée
est un précurseur obligé à la bipédie
est un précurseur obligé à la bipédie je
crois je me suis trompé de petites
erratum mais ouais c'est le c'est pas
l'ancêtre obligé de la bipédie c'est
l'ancêtre de la bipédie obligé voilà de
l'ancêtre de la bipédie obligatoire donc
désolé et donc ça c'est ce que vous avez
dû lire dans l'est dans l'est
et revue de presse on à l'ancêtre de la
bipédie voilà c'est ce que je vous ai
expliqué au début on a lens à être bip
on à l'ancêtre de la bipédie et cet
ancêtre de la bipédie c'est le lcc là
c'est la bipédie arboricole avec membres
postérieurs renforcée donc je vais
l'appeler elle s'est maintenant parce
que je vais pas répéter ça à chaque fois
voilà le lc ce serait l'ancêtre de la
bipédie et eux ils disent même pas ce
serait c'est l'ancêtre de la bipédie
lancé être obligé de la bipédie homme
lui drop la bombe dropped à bomber
il utilise pas le conditionnel dans
cette phrase donc j'ai quand même raison
quand ils disent que c'est l'ancêtre de
la bipédie il utilise pas du tout le
conditionnel aucune prudence dans cette
phrase alors moi je veux bien mais
comment tu dis que c'est l'ancêtre
obligé de la bipédie qu'est ce qui te
fait dire que c'est l'ancêtre obligé de
la bipédie ce serait effectivement un
ancêtre idéal à la bipédie idéalement
c'est vrai qu'on partirait d'une dune
d'un bip une bipédie arboricole avec les
membres postérieurs faible on passe par
une bipédie arboricole avec les membres
postérieurs fort et ensuite à une
bipédie terrestre chez bipédie terrestre
obligatoire chez les ch et les grands
sages mais voilà donc ce serait un
ancêtre idéal oui mais où est la preuve
de sa non parce que jusqu'à preuve du
contraire danubius est tout et c'est ce
qui explique très bien dans cet article
danubius c'est le seul grand singe du
miocène à fabre et à pratiquer 7 7bis
médian 7 bipédie arboricole que jusqu'à
présent on avait des squelettes de
pierrot l'api tqs de driot pittacus
dispano pittacus de ruud a piqué cus
rudaz pittacus on en a parlé il ya pas
longtemps dans les palais aux news
d'ailleurs voilà ça ce sont les ça ce
sont les grands sages du miocène
supérieur pour lesquelles on a des
squelettes et ils sont tous suspenseurs
donc il se suspendent dans les arbres
comme les comme les gibbons par exemple
donc ils ont donc ils sont comme ils
disent similaire aux grands singes
moderne à des degrés variés voilà et
après si on remonte encore plus loin on
tombe sur et kambo et proconsul et eux
c'est carrément des c'est carrément des
quadrupèdes de palm palm me grade
voilà donc et cambo et cambo et les
cercopithèque aux ide par exemple ce
sont des quadrupèdes palmie grade donc
si l'on remonte encore plus loin dans le
milieu scène on retombe sur des trucs
qui marchent basiquement comme des
babouins
ça veut dire qu'ils marchent ils sont
ils se suspendent même pas aux arbres
ils marchent sur le plat des mains donc
en gros jusqu'à preuve du contraire et
et en se basant sur sur le registre
fossile actuelle danubius c'est un cas
exceptionnel
c'est un cas isolé c'est le seul à être
comme ça on a un autre bipèdes
arboricole qui s'appellerait au pit et
cus mes oreilles au pit et cus
bah il est
il est assez loin dès la racine des
grands sages hélas hélas j'en arrive au
point qui me fait qui me fait le plus
tiquer dans cet article
elle est où la phylogénie bah oui là on
nomme une nouvelle espèce
elle est où la phylogénie la regarder
c'est le générique de fin la comme ça
c'est tout ça c'est le générique de fin
août à l'arrêt puis après vous avez les
images la plus faible appui dans les
images vous pouvez regarder pour
pourquoi il n'y a pas l'ombre d'une
phylogénie la même de la paperasse à la
fin il ya plus de paperasse à la fin que
de fil au génie elle est où la
phylogénie ou est ce qu'on nous dit où
est ce qu'on nous dit que dans nos vieux
si les positionner à un endroit de la
phylogénie où ça nous permet de dire ah
bah ok oui évidemment la ccl ancestrale
cette posture parce que si danubius il
est paumé au milieu de ces trucs là là
au milieu d'eux pirola pittacus driot
pittacus hispano pincus c'est juste une
exception au milieu de la règle qui est
d'être comme les grands singes actuels
c'est à dire quadrupèdes suspenseurs
quadripède suspenseurs voilà donc aller
où la phylogénie alors le seul moment où
on parle vaguement de phylogénie où on
évoque vaguement la phylogénie c'est
quand on lui dit que c'est possiblement
à driot pitt et signer alors pour pour
vous dire c'est tellement c'est
tellement succinct qu'il va falloir que
je le tape donc on nous dit ici voilà ça
drillo piscine est bien préservée voilà
diagnos différentiel la morphologie
cranio dentaire indique darwinius est un
trio pitt et signer et c'est pareil
enfin après il nous renvoie la diagnos
différentiel dans les méthodes mais il
ya toujours pas de phylogénie dans les
méthodes donc est arrivé là c'est quand
même à moi de venir vous montrer où se
placent les driot pitt dessinée dans la
phylogénie je veux dire c'est quand même
un mois de faire l'effort de montrer aux
gens mais si regardez driot pittacus il
est là drillo pittacus il est là il est
à la base de loyers entre à la base de
l'arbre juste avant le gorille l'humain
le chimpanzé ah oui mais on dit pas que
c'est un trio pittacus on dit que c'est
un trio pitt et signer or le problème
des trios pitt et signer à regarder
c'est que quand on n'a que des hôpitaux
cus bon on s'amuse mais quand on en a
plein bas on a eu ni résolution aller
driot pittacus pirola pittacus houran au
pit et cus tous les trucs tous les trucs
qui sont reliés les trios pitt et ciné
en fait c'est pas un clad c'est pas un
groupe monofil éthique on sait même pas
si c'est un groupe monofil éthique les
driot pitt et signer des fois des fois
on va placer gréco pittacus plus près de
bâtonnets voyez gréco pittacus par
exemple il ya des fois on voudrait bien
le placer ici là la base il ya des fois
où ces ora no pity q ce qu'on a envie de
placer ici à la base avec les gorilles
il ya des fois où
ou pire à la pythie cul s'il finit plus
bas il ya des fois où il ya pillay a pas
tous les trios pitt et signer là il y en
a beaucoup plus que ça les driot pitt et
signer on sait même pas si c'est un
groupe monofil éthique et eux ils nous
balancent abba voyez ça veut dire que la
bipédie aller ancestrale chez les grands
singes bah oui mais enfin
pirola pitt et q cela par exemple aidé
riou pittacus ils sont pas bipèdes
c'est eux mêmes qu'ils l'écrivent c'est
pas moi qui la vente la cee même qu'ils
écrivent donc je veux dire on sait même
pas on sait même pas s'il se place faut
pour pouvoir dire que danubius et
pertinents dans l'évolution de la
posture chez les grands singes et
notamment chez les gorilles donc là vous
avez les gorille là vous avez chat
pensée et là vous avez les humains enfin
les homininés il faudrait pouvoir
il faudrait pouvoir dire à coup sûr qu'à
coup sûr danut vieux se branche à la
base des driot pitesti n'est que du coup
sa posture à lui est ancestrale audry au
pit et signer et peut-être pour eux
mêmes par extension du cou à ceux clad
complet sauf que si danubius il est tout
seul perdu au milieu de cet arbre de
l'arbre des trios pitt et signer bas
c'est juste un cas de convergence
évolutive de plus comme aurait au pit
accuse donc aurait opté cus j'en parlais
tout à l'heure il est là voyez il est
super loin dans l'arbre phylogénétique
aurait opté cus donc pour lui il n'y a
pas trop de doute que sa bipédie à lui
sa bipédie arboricole elle est
convergente même est là pour driot
pittacus pour dire que ça va pour
danubius pour dire que pour être sûr que
sa bipédie n'est pas convergente avec
celle des humains qui se trouve là il
faudrait pouvoir être sûr que soit il se
branche à la base des driot pitt et
signer ici soi même qu'il se branche à
la base d
des hominidés ici donc pas en plus
gorilla plus homo ça fait hominidés donc
et ça et ça nulle part ça n'est démontré
donc où est ce qu'ils nous prouvent que
des news us à une quelconque pertinence
dans la question de est ce que oui ou
non la bipédie était initiale ou pas ça
n'est jamais questionné ça n'est jamais
démontré on ne nous démontre jamais la
pertinence de ce nouveau taxons de cette
nouvelle espèce pour le débat sur
l'origine de la bipédie et alors ça ça
c'est un très très gros problème dans
cette danse est dans ce nouvel article
donc voilà je ne conteste pas je ne
conteste absolument pas le fait que
cette espèce était bipède
je ne conteste absolument pas la
pertinence
enfin l'autorité et les expertises des
gens qui ont écrit cet article
je comptais moi mais mes gros points
mais gros point noir sur cette étude
c'est le matos à mon avis le matos est
pas très joli et beaucoup des mesures
qui ont été faites dessus il faudrait
faudrait les étudier au cas par cas
voilà
définir le deuxième point qui m'inquiète
c'est la définition d'une nouvelle d'un
nouveau mode de locomotion chez les
grands singes alors même qu'il n'existe
pas chez les singes moderne donc
hypothèse note est stable ou très
faiblement est stable ou très
difficilement testable ou voit la pensée
en ce que vous voulez allez-y dans les
commentaires dites moi ce que vous en
pensez et surtout le gros point noir
c'est l'absence totale de phylogénie qui
est déjà un problème en soi quand on
veut définir une nouvelle espèce mais
qui en plus bas à valide tout le
discours parce qu'on ne sait pas s'ils
ont du coup on ne peut pas dire si c'est
convergent ou pas en l'absence de fil au
génie c'est impossible de dire si la
bipédie de danube youth et convergente
ou pas et si ça se trouve il aurait même
trouvé que danubius était et est même
plus proche de l'être humain vu que
danew ces bipèdes
si ça se trouve il l'aurait même trouvé
qu'il était plus proche de l'être humain
que
que du chimpanzé et alors là ça aurait
voulu enfin il aurait démontré l'origine
européenne de l'être humain qu'ils
essaient de démontrer l'appui la
découverte de ces de ces fameuses
empreinte bipèdes en grèce donc là je
vous rappelle un souvenir qui est très
très vieux là mais il avait trouvé d une
piste d'empreintes de deux grands sages
bipèdes en grèce donc et que peut-être
c'était un ancêtre des hominidés ou
peut-être pas ou peut-être que c'était
justement un cas de convergence
évolutive comores et au pit et cus voilà
est donc en l'absence de phylogénie bas
on le saura pas voilà donc moi - des
articles comme ça qui font presque
exprès de d'esquiver la question ça
m'ennuie je vais vous montrer justement
comment ouais parce que là faut quand
même le voir ça c'est je vais vous
montrer comment dans les communiqués de
presse ils vous présentent 7,7
phylogénie parce que évidemment dans les
communiqués de presse les gens sont pas
idiots ils veulent savoir si c'est une
convergence ou pas bien regardé comment
il traite le truc
donc voilà ça c'est une image que j'ai
tirée d'un communiqué de presse voici
une phylogénie un là il ya une file au
génie et regarder âge approximatif de
danubius donc voyez la ligne rouge la
tacatacatique attaque et on nous dit à
regarder c'est juste à la base entre le
gorille le chimpanzé et l'humain voyez
c'est c'est là qu'il se place d'un news
est à ta ligne elle passe aussi par là
et voilà
l'article ne démontre pas que cette
ligne que des news ne pourrait pas tout
aussi bien se positionner ici alors j'ai
toute confiance dans le fait que c'est
pas un orang outan je veux dire les
orangs outans ils ont quand même une
tête suffisamment facile à reconnaître
ils ont ils ont une morphologie
suffisamment différente des autres
grands singes pour être différenciées
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que voilà
méthodologiquement parlant baïse exclut
pas et du coup les driot pitt et signer
il se placerait la du coup nous voyons
nous on nous montre pas si danubius il
est il est là s'il est là dans les trios
pin dessinée s'il est à la base des
trios pitt et ciné en haut des deux
dans les plu dérivés des trios pitt à
signer on nous dit pas tout ça on nous
dit pas tout ça du coup ça me fait me
demander si je si les auteurs de cet
article comprennent à quel point ces
problématiques ne pas avoir inclus une
phylogénie là dedans voilà donc
donc voilà c'est ce que j'en pense bas
c'est que c'est que on va falloir
attendre la suite si ça se trouve c'est
peut-être pour ça qu'ils n'ont pas
inclus de phylogénie a peut-être qu'ils
le savent très bien que justement la
phylogénie sera critiqué que et que
peut-être que justement avec une file au
génie arriveront à démontrer le
l'origine européenne de l'homme qu'il
cherche tend à démontrer
donc peut-être qu'ils ont envie d'en
faire un deuxième article dans nature
voilà ça se trouve c'est ça donc je ne
sais pas on verra la suite mais voilà
pour moi le mystère restera entier pour
moi il ya enfin j'ai bien envie de
conclure que le mystère reste entier
mais j'ai horreur de conclure comme ça
donc non le mystère restera entier là il
ya clairement un problème dans cette ya
clairement au moins trois problèmes dans
cette étude
voilà merci à tous d'avoir suivi cette
petite émission ce petit paléo newsflash
n oubliez pas de vous abonner pour ne
rien manquer d'anciens ciao